Gary Vaynerchuk is a fast-talking
irreverent business guru who calls
himself a serial entrepreneur so his
name is Gary Vaynerchuk and what he did
is he trained me how to uh to train my
my palate my next guest is the host of
Wine Library TV a very popular video
blogs and featuring The Wall Street
Journal and Time magazine because
welcome Gary Vaynerchuk
let's [ __ ] provide value right the
[ __ ] now
please don't [ __ ] me when you give a
[ __ ] load of value upfront you deal
people into buying [ __ ] I'm given three
cents here [ __ ] every person is
true including me fancies himself of
knowing where things are going is
grossly under estimating the culture
ship that we're living for if you need
to bet on your strengths and don't give
a [ __ ] about what you suck at college is
the racket other than the jobs lawyers
doctor I know the cliche ship you're not
watching this for warrior [ __ ] I want
the sweat and the pain it's the process
I want the work I don't want the stuff
give [ __ ] what anybody says about me
because I trust my intuition I'm gonna
build the biggest best agency of all
time in your [ __ ] mouth
if you want this if you want bling bling
if you want to buy the Jets if you want
to do [ __ ] work that's how you get it
you are 100 [ __ ] percent in charge of
your life stop [ __ ] bitching I'm very
driven by the climate but the game is my
drug the process the climb the that is
the drug that drives me that is my
oxygen